mit colt colt colvin komplett
constrictor eines der heißesten themen
ist wissen wir auch einer der
anwendungsbereich neben dem investment
ist die zahlung und nutzung als währung
aber inwiefern ist es genau jetzt mitte
20 21 möglich können wir gerade schon
alltägliche dinge mit crypto bezahlen
und erledigen oder bleibt es ein weit
entferntes wunschdenken um das
herauszufinden habe ich einen tag auf
bezahlung mit euros verzichtet und
versucht alles mit krippe zu zahlen um
für erledigt oder einen teil des
frühstücks mittagessens einkaufen und
einem sportplatz finden waren unser ziel
für diesen tag ob das geklappt hat wo es
schwierigkeiten gab und warum gilt für
dieses video extra ins ausland gefahren
sind erfahrt ihr in diesem video
herzlich willkommen im bitcoin sitzen
wir starten in köln meine heimatstadt
und schauen inwiefern das möglich ist
mit bitcoin zu leben ist es wirklich mit
tätowierungen zu zahlen
natürlich nicht wenn es um so halb
geöffnete so einfach mitnehmen können
mit dem aber ich kann nicht zufällig mit
crypto währungen bei euch bezahlen oder
die können wir nicht völlig mit clubtour
währungen bezahlen oder nicht
danke natürlich war uns das vorher schon
bewusst weder beim bäcker noch im
supermarkt oder im café ist es möglich
mit bitcoins zu bezahlen anders sieht
das aber in arnheim aus einer kleinen
stadt in holland die sich selber als
bitcoin city bezeichnet ich bin ehrlich
gespannt inwiefern dass er möglichst
überall mit crypto zu zahlen ist es ein
konzept ist es so dass man in jedem
laden dort zahlen kann gibt es viele
digital nomads die dort ihr komplettes
leben mit bitcoin bestreiten und
allgemein wie sehr ist es da vertreten
das werden wir sehen und testen wenn ich
einfach
[Musik]
essen angekommen wir sind in arnheim wir
sind in fucking bitcoin city und was die
stadt kann und was es hier für
möglichkeiten gibt das checken jetzt
arnheim bitcoin staat das sind alle
restaurants orte an denen wir mit
bitcoin bezahlen können darunter
klamotten lakers hotels einkaufs land
wirklich komplett normale einkaufsläden
das problem wir haben nur euro dabei wir
brauchen natürlich bitcoin um in dieser
begrenzt hier zu bezahlen das beste wäre
natürlich wenn wir irgendwie ganz easy
unsere euros in bitcoins umwandeln
könnten
oh warte mal es gibt einen etm an denen
genau das tun kann und damit starten
also irgendwo hier sollte der ltm sein
damit wir geld abheben können damit wir
dann gleich unser ruit mit bitcoin
kaufen würden vielleicht kriegen wir
wirklich ein bisschen ort mit bitcoin
geglaubt hinter sieht das ziel leute
werden probieren coffee shop zu finden
indem wir ein bisschen ort mit dritt
coin kaufen können probieren jetzt den
atem zu finden dort geld einzuzahlen
dadurch bitcoin auf unsere lightning
rolle zu bekommen und dann auch uns
vielleicht ist er ja sogar hier drin
[Musik]
o3d leistungskomponente also seid
kürzester zeit hat die niederländische
regierung das ein bisschen stärker
reguliert und irgendwas wurde da
umgestellt irgendwas ist neu und seit
kurzem funktionierte ltm nicht mehr so
wie er die ganze zeit funktioniert
wir gehen weiter am jacob legen was zu
essen finden können dass man mit
betreuen bezahlt 394.000 z also 145
dollar ca sind auch der saturn world
angekommen das bedeutet wir können jetzt
essen gehen wir können jetzt einkaufen
gehen und das tun auch der gesamtindex
auf seiner karte von einem verein
gedruckt der sich dafür einsetzt dass
hier mehr bigpoint akzeptiert wird dort
bei dieser shop genannt und es möglichst
zwischenstand die fehlerquote von 100%
wir haben zwei sachen ausprobiert und
beide sachen haben nicht funktioniert
man uns jetzt auf dem weg zu optionen 3
und hoffentlich sehen wir dann auch
endlich mal was von der bitcoins ich
erhalte alle verletzt wir sitzen
tatsächlich in einem restaurant und wir
können
bitcoins zahlen so vermied least one
club sandwich und das bier ist auch mein
erstes bitcoin wir es schmeckt dezentral
ja ja ja nicht gut aus
frau ich bin max
ja und dann war es endlich soweit unsere
erste zahlung mit bitcoin in dem
restaurant allgemein meine erste zahlung
mit bitcoin für ein produkt ich war
ehrlich ein bisschen aufgeregt und im
endeffekt war es absolut unspektakulär
reported
zahlen
[Musik]
alter tatsächlich funktioniert wir
konnten unser gesamtes essen einfach so
instant mit bitcoins über lightning
network bezahlt
[Musik]
mittlerweile sind wir in einem stadtteil
der wirklich lebenswert die ganzen
anderen stadtteile wo wir gerade
unterwegs waren waren so ein bisschen
grau und trist aber hier könnte ich mir
wirklich vorstellen so meine bitcoin
millionen dann doch irgendwann
auszugeben wenn sie denn dann irgendwann
kommen würden denn in selber gar nicht
mehr ein bitcoin investiert gar nicht im
crypto dings unterwegs bin ich
interessiert aber trotzdem und wenn es
so weitergeht und mehr städte
restaurants eben welche lokale kripo
zahlungen akzeptieren dann wird das
immer interessanter
man mag ist unser nächstes pott kaffee
nach dem essen kein problem let's go my
way wind kommt muss die man erreichen
glaubt niemand niemand ist darauf
vorbereitet people of the world wird von
heute sind
[Musik]
mit kaffee eins scheint zu funktionieren
so ist es im wert von city also jetzt
noch druck mich interessiert wirklich
was ihr von kultur zahlungen haltet weil
ja viele leute von euch wahrscheinlich
auch investiert sind alle wissen ist
super volatil das macht vielleicht
gerade noch nicht so mega viel sinn das
als zahlungsmittel zu benutzen es könnte
aber dabei helfen die gesamte
kulturszene voranzutreiben weil man eben
einen teil des nutzen dann auch wirklich
im alltag nutzt also schreibt mir gerne
mal in die kommentare was ihr davon
haltet crypto im alltag als zahlungen zu
benutzen oder was sie davon halten würde
wenn das möglich wäre interessiert mich
wirklich und ich sage das nicht nur um
kommentare zu schreiben weil ich glaube
da gehen die meinungen ziemlich krass
auseinander
aber es wundert mich nicht dass wenige
leute mit bekannte zahlen so wie die
leute reagieren wenn wir hier reinkommen
und sagen wir möchten hiermit können
bezahlen selbst in den läden die damit
werben dass eine tür stehen haben ist es
scheinbar wirklich selten ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich bin ein bisschen
enttäuscht ist der leo gerade schon
gesagt ich habe so ein bisschen gehofft
dass man empfangen wird wie an so einem
super charger
da kommt man mit einem tesla und alle
sind so was geht was für eine version
hast du wie sieht es bei dir aus aber so
ist es gar nicht also es findet hier
kein austausch statt es scheinbar nicht
so dass hier eine riesen bitcoin
community ist die das probiert wirklich
nach vorne zu bringen aber es wirkt wie
eine halb ausgestorbene idee die vor
drei jahren mal super hype war
nichtsdestotrotz akzeptiert scheinbar
dieser spaß
komplett normaler einkaufsladen
hoffentlich bekommt weg räumen
er ist im alltag könnte wenn wir hier
wohnen würden unseren komplett normalen
täglichen einkauf mit köln bezahlen und
das macht dann das finde ich mache jetzt
schon wieder mehr den unterschied
das ist nicht so ein café das irgendwie
mal bitcoin angefangen hat zu
akzeptieren sondern ganz einkaufen geht
und mit bitcoin bezahlen ist das was von
uns ich brauche sie bekommen aber es
geht perfekt war
das ist bisher mein absolutes highlight
und das hat so flüssig funktioniert das
könnte ich mir vorstellen das würde man
in seinem alltag implementieren ja es
funktioniert es geht das vielleicht auch
so ein bisschen die frage dabei ist
funktioniert es geht warum machen es
dann nicht mehr die leute fangen nicht
an mit bitcoins zu zahlen solange die
leben das nicht akzeptieren also liegt
wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen an den
läden das zu machen
bei so einem schönen städte trip muss
man natürlich auch noch irgendwo
schlafen ja das problem jetzt im hotel
modell ist weil hier war zumindest mal
bitcoin zahlungen möglich und jetzt
schauen wir mal ob das immer noch so ist
oder ob die das mittlerweile schon
wieder abgeschafft haben und wenn ja
warum
als postbote jetzt ist noch posten genau
dasselbe wie mit dem etm am anfang wo
wir geld einzahlen wollten geld
auszahlen wollte
es hat sich irgendwas geändert und das
hat dazu geführt dass viele der anbieter
jetzt keine bitcoin zahlung mehr
akzeptieren was schade ist es scheinbar
geht es daher wieder ein bisschen weg
vom bitcoin und das nicht weil die leute
da keinen bock drauf haben sondern weil
sich irgendwelche regularien geändert
haben weil sachen unklar sind da kann
man dann natürlich auch nichts machen
hotels aber gut aus wenn ich eine nacht
drüber schlafen wenn es denn möglich
gewesen unter bitcoin city habe ich mir
ein bisschen was anderes vorgestellt
jetzt etwas anderes erhoffen aber
nichtsdestotrotz war es cool das ganze
mal im alltag zu nutzen und nicht nur
damit zu spekulieren sondern einen
kleinen teil also auch wenn der teil nur
minimal ist ein teil des nutzens den
mann mit kripo hat abzudecken und dem
wirklich im einsatz zu sehen war jetzt
wirklich ein bisschen ja nicht dann aber
auf der anderen seite macht es einfach
bock sich mit diesen sachen
auseinanderzusetzen und man merkt dass
wir nicht stillstehen das könnte alles
viel schneller gehen aber alleine zu
merken dass was passiert alleine zu
merken dass es in eine neue richtung
geht macht mir echt mega bock ja im
prinzip fast aus vielen dank dass ihr
das video angeschaut habe das hat eine
menge spaß gemacht vergesst nicht das
video vom studio zu gucken was diese
woche raus gekommen ist und vergesst
nicht beide kanäle zu abonnieren
denn es geht weiter mit krassen
innovationen bald auf dem studio canal
und vielleicht auch hier wenn euch das
thema gefällt dann werde ich mich darum
kümmern wo ich genau das in zukunft
weiter zu zeigen was gut schöne woche